I think Bitcoin is basically an energy
business right try to tell that to the
minor that it has no value so an example
how is it an energy business so I know a
company that put down
$8,000 in and as a result it spits out
Bitcoin and so if you tell them that it
has no value well they've just put down
$8,000 so if I say to them can I take
your Bitcoin for free they'll say
absolutely not I technically paid $8,000
for it so say you have an iPhone right
and you paid $1,000 for the iPhone and I
say to you can I please have that iPhone
for free are you going to get give it to
me for free well why would I right I
know because you paid cuz you paid
$1,000 for it that's true so why would
you give it to me for free so if I then
said to you do you know what it's second
hand I'll actually take it for
$750 so now because of market conditions
and supply and demand obviously as you
know the price can fluctuate like it can
with gold with Bitcoin and any other but
the thing is